do you think there'll be attempts on
Lucy lippy's life in prison I think that
there are prisoners uh in the women's
estate who will think nothing of trying
to get a trophy uh like Lucy let me
my name is Vanessa frake I serve 27
years in the prison service the last 11
as Governor at wormwood scrubs today I'm
going to be answering anonymous
questions from the lad Bible public
where do prisoners get drugs and phones
from
if only I knew the answer to that from
many many different sources Contraband
like phones and drugs come into prison
in all different shapes and sizes you
know I've had dead pigeons fall at my
feet
flat on their back sewn up the middle
stuff with drugs our drug dogs have
found tennis balls that have been thrown
over the walls stuffed with drugs they
come in from the courts they come in
from bogus solicitors they come in from
staff the problem with drugs in prison
is that it is never ending as soon as
you shut one door you can bet your
bottom dollar that another one will open
should we bring back the death penalty
oh that's a difficult one isn't it if
you'd have asked me this 20 years ago
without doubt I'd have said absolutely
yes and I'd have probably been the first
to volunteer to do the Death Watch maybe
I've gone a bit soft in my old age but
I'm not so sure that that is the right
way to go these days yes there are some
horrendous evil crimes
um that happen these days but is it
really as a society do we want to take
that step backwards I'm not so sure that
we do there have been a lot of
miscarriages of Justice over the last
couple of years and I don't know how we
as a society would live with ourselves
if we executed the wrong person
what will prison be like for Lucy letby
she will probably spend the majority of
her time initially
by herself in a segregation unit she
won't be allowed to mix with the general
population of the prison at this precise
time for obvious reasons to protect not
only her but other prisoners
so for her I'm afraid it's going to be
quite a lonely existence at some stage
though the prison authorities will risk
assess and make that decision to try and
integrate her into the general
population but I shouldn't think that
that will won't be for a good few years
yet you know child killers in this day
and age are seen as the lowest of the
low in prison the likes of Lucy Levy
will probably always have to look over
her shoulder you know prison staff can
be there most of the time but there will
always be that occasion when they won't
be about do you think there'll be
attempts on Lucy lippy's life in prison
I think that there are prisoners uh in
the women's estate who will think
nothing of trying to get a trophy uh
like Lucy Lippy
um you know there are there are some
serious
um prisoners locked up in the female
estate who would would have a go in the
blink of an eye if given the opportunity
what makes somebody evil
I don't think that you're necessarily
born evil I don't think that you're
necessarily
um turn evil overnight I think it's it's
a very
um difficult question everybody has the
the ability to be evil it's just whether
we decide to
act on that or not without a doubt I've
come across evil prisoners without a
doubt Myra hindley Rose West Beverly
Hallett you know all these people
um
can be described as evil you know
they're they're serial killers how can
you say that somebody like that is an
evil Beverly also known as the angel of
death she uh was responsible I think it
was for four or five deaths of babies
and about I think it was another nine or
so attempted murders
um she was brought into a Holloway
prison she went to the psychiatric unit
and was later transferred out of
um Holloway to Broadmoor which is where
she sits today Rose West
um a typical psychopath I'd say very uh
willing to do whatever she's told to do
um but all the time you're looking at
her and thinking yes you're quite
cunning I mean I had Rose West on my
wing in uh before she went to Winchester
crown for her trial I was actually
myself in the governor the person that
informed her that Fred West had killed
himself now Rose West didn't bat an
eyelid when the governor
came onto the wing he came and he said
to me I need to speak to Rose West
I unlocked her stood there next to him
and he's told her that Fred had killed
himself that lunch time it was New
Year's Day
and this was around tea time
Rose West didn't blink she didn't Flinch
she didn't cry she didn't shout out
nothing there was no emotion no reaction
I do believe that Rose thought that Fred
now he had died would
um
all everything that she was charged with
would go away obviously that wasn't the
case she's one of the few
all-life whole life sentence
um female prisoners
um so Rose was was easy to manage she
was no problem
she did what she was told
um
you know she had thick bottleneck
glasses
she was constantly knitting although we
continually never really knew what she
was knitting it just seemed that she was
knitting on and on and on without sort
of really a pattern or shape taking
place Myra hindley I've only met Myra
hindley just once and that was at uh
cooking wood which was a a prison down
in Kent and Holloway used to transfer
convicted women down to cook and wood on
a regular basis basically to free up
space at Holloway
and one day I was I was the most Junior
member of staff
there were two other staff and I think
we took four prisoners from Holloway
down to cook and wood and when we got to
the receptions unit there was a like
this big fat
huge officer I don't think I've ever
seen such such a
huge woman
um and her like shirt was was so tight
she'd actually had to sew herself into
it which I always thought was a bit of a
joke really but um anyways she screamed
at the top of her voice Myra
and I was like
clearly clearly Myra's coming
um and the officer said next to me you
know who who's coming don't you man when
I haven't got a clue she went that'll be
Myra hindley she's the orderly she works
in receptions down here I was like all
right right okay fine fair enough
anyways well I can only describe as a
bag lady rocked up she had a like a a
long brown cardigan on that was
threadbare at the elbows
um her hair was a mousy Brown sort of
with some sort of dreadful almost like
feather haircut she sort of shuffled
along her her
skirt was old and worn you know she she
honestly if you'd have if you'd have
passed her in the street you wouldn't
have recognized her anyway she came up
to us asked us all if we wanted a cup of
tea I said yeah two Two Sugars please
and off she throttled
um she came back gave us our tea drank
it it was fine
somebody once said to me you didn't
actually drink it did you and I was like
well yeah I was thirsty
who's the scariest person you've ever
met and why
oh
um I presume you mean prisoner there
were quite a few scary staff I I won't
lie when I first joined the job but uh
prisoner-wise
I'm not sure if I ever thought any
prisoner was scary I may have been wary
of them there is a difference
um I think if you ever thought that
somebody was scary or you were scared
you couldn't have done the job so I'm
not sure I ever thought a prisoner was
scary
I was at um up in Wakefield prison which
was
um called monster man excuse me it was
called Monster Mansion at one time
because of the amount of sex offenders
there and I was up there having a look
around with a view to transferring up
there I hastened to add I didn't but um
I did bump into Colin Ireland at one
point
um whilst I was there
um he was quite a big bloke about six
foot six by six foot six wide he was the
gay killer in sofa Soho he lured men
back to his flat where he murdered them
um now he was he was probably the one
that made me do a double take
um but as as for scary as such no I
don't think that there were particularly
any prisoners that I found scary
if he went to prison tomorrow how would
you behave that is a really easy
question for me to answer having watched
prisoners closely for nigh on 30 years I
would be politeness itself I would be up
to all sorts underneath but to officers
and prison staff I'd be polite I'd get
myself a job probably uh the tea girl
making Cups of Tea for for officers
because they're unlocked a lot I'd get
to hear what officers talk about because
they can't help but talking about
themselves I'd see who were good
officers who were bad officers who were
officers that I might want to corrupt a
little bit that's how I would behave in
prison what's interesting how prisoners
act because you know women act totally
different to men you know they have a
laugh and a joke with each other they
make friends quite easily they have
sexual relationships with each other
where they might Maybe
heterosexual on the outside
um men are totally different they're
quite
um reserved they're quite they don't
make friendships easily and certainly
you know there's no open homosexuality
um per se
oh I'm not gonna do that one
what was it it was it was have you had
any famous people in prison I'm sick of
answering that question because you know
these people are absolute we had Pete
Doherty when I was at scrubs can we yeah
can we do that Pete Doherty formerly of
The Libertines
um and baby shambles I think I think he
got about three months sentence for uh
either contempt of court or
drugs charges one of the two we decided
because he was
um on drugs that we would send him to
our detox unit it was a unit about 54 55
uh prisoners so only a small unit but
all of them were detoxing from drugs or
attempting to detox from drugs so that's
where he went
um and then sort of a couple of days
later we we heard from the staff on on
the detox unit that they were going
through sell cards quicker than the
anything because every every cell has a
cell card outside it has the prisoner's
name his number who belongs in that cell
and these cell his peaked artists uh
cell cards were disappearing at an
alarming rate
um and he was basically autographing
them and giving them out to prisoners on
the wing
um and then I came into work one Sunday
morning
uh to be greeted by I think it was the
news of the world
um and on the front page was Pete
Doherty uh smoking joints being
photographed with a mobile phone uh on
the detox unit with several prisoners it
did sort of great on me a bit that we
had tried to help him put him in the
best place possible that we could think
of putting him
um in order to try and help him with his
uh with his drug habit and clearly you
know he kind of threw that back in the
prison's face
which TV show films portray British
prisons the best well that's a really
good question I like that question
because
um I get so fraught at some of these uh
TV shows and prisons and you know
there's one there's one currently called
screw
um that um I just can't watch I think I
watched five minutes of it if if
somebody followed me around and made a
program about my day as a governor at
wormwood scrubs they'd probably be bored
to tears and fallen asleep I understand
the artistic license I understand
there's got to be drama in it but some
of it virgins on the
the absolute ridiculous
um but saying that there was a a film
with Sean Bean
um about 12 18 months ago called time
which I thought was brilliant Sean Bean
played it brilliantly the you know
inside of jail for the first night
um that whole that whole scene was was
brilliant and I thought thought that one
was probably one of the best
oh has anyone escaped on your watch I
have had an escape it was an armed
escape
from a hospital
um whilst I was governor at wormwood
scrubs
um the circumstances of the incident you
know
um I'm not afraid to admit it's
something that haunted me for a long
time the prisoner concerned feigned in
illness
um we thought that he was faking we had
intelligence that he would fake an
illness to get out of the jail a doctor
came along and quite correctly you know
life should take precedent
um said that he should go out to
hospital we contacted the local police
and said that we had a prisoner who was
being sent out to hospital that we had
grave concerns over the police said they
were far too busy to attend but would
send a patrol car by
we found the director of the hospital
security and asked them to put extra
security guards
um at the ambulance entrance which they
agreed to
I sent three staff and double cuffed The
Prisoner so he was cuffed like that and
then cuffed to an officer about five ten
minutes after the ambulance had left the
gate I got a phone call from the control
room
saying that the staff had just phoned
the ambulance had been held up by armed
gunmen and thankfully the staff did
absolutely the right thing they gave the
gunman the keys of the handcuffs
and the Prisoner made good his Escape it
was an absolute Carnage of a scene
at the three staff that I sent out to
that hospital one member of Staff
um
moved from being an officer to an admin
grade
one member of staff was medically
retired another member of staff was
medically retired and later killed
himself so that is my uh dealings with
her with an escape and that is one of my
biggest regrets of my life
said right okay you're gonna have to
come upstairs with me
there's a Northwest area search team
waiting for you I was like oh God here
we go and I knew the game was up then so
I walked up the stairs there was two
dogs
a couple of handlers three or four
different offices there was a governor
there and I just saw it right it's over